who's buying these shares in these
companies who is it was our average
investor ages about 27 I'm sorry what
average investor age is about 27 20 22 7
to 7 you put in a 2 in front of 7 I
would guess 47 no 27 young people yes
have no money and don't care about their
futures that's what we're told no not at
all okay
yeah it's young self-directed investors
got it yeah and they think this is fun
no they think this is diversification
God and they and they they are very in
tuned with the idea that ownership and
possession and utility are not the same
thing and they don't have to be
connected with each other anymore
ownership and possession and utility
right it doesn't they don't have anyone
in the same so that's that's needed for
them and becoming self-directed and you
know they're they're more comfortable
investing self-directed behind
themselves learning doing the diligence
themselves and then making a decision as
compared to like it's not like they're
going into JPMorgan to make that
decision for them right in fact they've
been alienated in most cases by those
types of institutions and so here you've
got young people who want to be
diversified who are thinking about their
futures and they want to have access to
this so it's nice of them we have a very
diverse investor base you could have a
21 year old investing with a 70 year old
in a car that the 70 year old grew up in
and the 21 year old thinks is cool and
that's that's something that is
important Robin Hood when they pitched
me they had the same idea which was
similar idea which was like I was like
what are you guys doing at Robin Hood
they're like we're gonna make it we're
gonna make an app that gets young people
to trade stocks I'm like young people
don't want to trade stocks they they
don't get it they don't want to do it
they're like yeah no no we have a hook
we're gonna get them in I'm like what's
the hook they're like we're not gonna
charge them it was like so you're gonna
get a group of people who have never
done this behavior and the way you're
gonna build a business around them is to
lose money from letting them do it for
free
correct and they said yes I said I'm in
because if you can convert a group of
people who aren't doing the behavior yes
what is the prize see this what you got
to think about what is what do you win
not what are the chances I win and this
is the fundamental problem
with people who are not degenerate
gamblers they think I have a 4 it's
gonna be 51 to one that I pull the ace
of spades out of the deck mm-hmm so I
got a 1 in 52 chance roughly 2%
it's called 2% for let's say you took
two of the aces out and you just left
two of the aces in the ace of spades in
these hearts you got 50 cards in the
deck if I told you pull the ace of
spades and get $100 would you do it
wait what's the water what's what do I
have to put at risk whatever amount you
$100 right
you okay pay a dollar pay a dollar I'll
give you back a hundred if you pull the
in suspense right so my expected outcome
is yeah two bucks and I'm paying a
dollar for two correct I would do it all
day long of course most people would
never do it because the majority case is
you do not win the hundred for your one
dollar bet but anybody who can do math
or thinks about it is this those are
better odds so you should do it and
that's why people who are playing poker
calculate pot odds and just do basic
calculations worth doing or not
sure and in your case it does seem silly
like cars okay whatever car people are
weird what you're looking at is what are
the chances that finite coveted items
increase in value over the next twenty
years correct it's a hundred percent
correct
they're coveted they're not going to go
away now as the global market becomes
Western yep the number of people who
covered covet the things the West's
covet goes up correct so I look at this
as a global play it is a global play
people in China at some point and in
Japan figure it out McAllen was a great
scotch and in the Middle East they did
you know what they did with all the
Macallan they bought it all up
same thing Pappy Van Winkle whatever
wines so all these wineries and then
what happened when the Middle East
started printing money from their oil
they started going to Ferrari and saying
we'll take all of them and Ferrari
doubled their I know if this is turnout
but I was told at some point the Middle
East was buying so many Ferraris that
they were
buying their production right they
doubled their production to keep up with
the demand
from the Middle East alone and that half
the Ferraris we're just being shipped in
the Middle East with crazy wacky custom
stuff on them and never being driven yep
and that's somewhere in the Middle East
there's rows of these things there's
thousands of them owned by individuals
that yeah if they were on the market
would I don't know what that would do to
the market but anyway is the play here
that people in India and China will join
the middle class the upper become rich
and ultra rich and want to buy these
things I believe that I mean I think
that's that's the goal right people go
from sort of shows of wealth to stores
of wealth and you know these are you
can't reproduce the the marquee
Lamborghini the marquee Ferrari the
marquee Porsche right they're just
they're just ingrained in society and as
we keep going to more and more
homogenized things it seems to me that
these these handmade these these analog
things have that inherent value that's
going to be very important and I think
young people get that I mean I certainly
did the other thing that I really always
thought about was so I have a limited
set of resources right and in that
limited set of revisit things I like I
like collectible cars right that's
something that I'm really personally
passionate about so for me I always
thought about if I have $100,000 let's
say that I'm gonna dedicate to this
thing that I care about I could take all
100 and buy an investment / car that I
use and enjoy and I'm sub-optimally
invested on both ends if I use it I'm
hurting my investment if I don't use it
I'm hurting my enjoyment right but am I
better off buying this $60,000 version
of the same exact car driving it every
weekend to get coffee I care about it
not worry about it and take 40,000 and
invest it with Riley Road across all of
mine oh great that's right